- AI and voice is gonna be game changing.
The way that our grandparents
look at an iPhone,
a lot of you are going to
look at AI voice that way.
It's going to change your life.
(upbeat music)
You got your perspective.
(applause)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
- So, Gary, thank you again.
Like we said, my name is Drew.
I'm on the marketing team here at FEVO.
There's also Lillian at the top
as well as Betty, our CMO.
I'm really excited to both ask you
a lot of some pre-submitted questions
that people have been submitting
over the last several weeks.
And we'll also pull up a couple of people
to ask you some stuff on their own.
So, so let's yeah, let's get into it.
I think there's a good
opportunity to sort of
kick off this hour with asking you
sort of a wide ranging question, right?
There's been a lot of
change over the last year,
where we've historically been FEVO
in the live entertainment
and sports space.
- Yup.
- And I think there's a good,
a good way to kick it off is
what are some of the
consumer engagement trends
that you've seen, whether they've changed,
or how their, how this past year has,
has set up for the future?
- I mean, the impact of
COVID on consumer behavior,
is extraordinary.
Like I promise you that
every single person here,
is grossly underestimating
the impact of it.
And it's not as simple as like,
we're not in the office,
or live event like,
by show of hands, and I'll try to go fast
on the 22 screens here.
By show of hands how many people
here have bought something
on the internet as a consumer good.
Like a toothpaste,
deodorant, shampoo, food,
that they had never bought before
pre-COVID because they
were buying, hold up,
I mean, do you understand
how big of a deal that is?
Every hand going up?
It also means that you might be ordering
from Seamless or Postmates or Uber eats
or from a restaurant,
locally that you tried,
that now becomes your main
restaurant, not the one,
I mean, this is a big deal.
Like I'm no longer going to fly
to Madrid and give a keynote
and then leave right away.
I'm gonna actually enjoy Madrid,
for two days because I'm
gonna work from Zoom,
back in New York during
the day, but like, not,
like this is big, big, right?
And I think anybody who
doesn't realize that
is because they're worried
that it's gonna hurt their business,
and they just want it to go back to 2019.
But they're not paying
attention to the human being.
This is going to affect companies.
I mean, there's some big Google,
there's some big companies Google down
that have over 50% of
their their employees
telling them they don't
want to ever come back
to the office ever.
And then there's a bunch of people
in here that want to punch
through kids in the mouth
and can't wait to get back to the office.
Like, you know how it is, I get it.
But just because you might go
back to normal in your mind,
even though you've already made plenty
of new decisions that
you don't even realize,
let there be no confusion.
On the flip side,
every live event in 2022
is gonna act exactly like
it did in 2019, all of them.
Like we're not gonna, not
like it's just, we're humans.
We're going to congregate.
Could some people decide
they don't want to go?
Sure.
I would argue, there's a lot
of people that realize how much
they love sporting events and
concerts during this time.
And may double up in 2022 and 2023.
So those are some of the themes
that are running through my head.
- It's funny, actually,
I was talking to Ari
about this exact thing last week.
And he said the exact same thing.
There's going to be a
lot of pent up demand for
not being able to do these things
over the last year and a
half, year and whatever.
- Oh my God.
Everybody who used to complain
about sitting in traffic
for an hour, when they went to
the Washington football team game, is now,
that's right you know, that was for you.
Is now gonna be thrilled
to sit in that traffic after two years.
(Gary stammers)
so I think there's gonna be some really
extreme consumer habits,
consumption habits.
I've watched more fucking
TV in the last 12 months,
than I've watched the last 12 years.
I've added HBO Max and
Hulu, and like, you know,
so there's just so many things.
I think I play chess now,
because of Queen's Gambit.
Something I wouldn't have even watched
had there not been COVID.
That like, just think about that shit.
- Yeah, it's very interesting.
So in thinking of the way our days
and our routines have changed,
what has changed in
your own daily routine,
that you've either picked
up and you want to continue
or you found yourself falling off from?
- You know I love people, which
is why I think social media,
when you don't just use it as
a blasting, so real for me.
I've been shocked by like,
even notice what I did
with Chanelle just now
and I'm clicking around, right?
You see.
I'm looking at Sarah Houston right now.
I'm looking at Jake Ben S. you
know, I'm looking at Randy S.
Like I'm looking right?
Because I need human interaction.
I've been blown away, Paul
B. is in the building.
I've been blown away by
how much I can feel y'all
in this format.
It's not a hundred, but it's fucking 96.
And in that 96, it's gonna
change a lot of things for me.
I'm gonna be much more
efficient with meetings.
You know, I play in VIP life.
I'm trying to get to dinner with a CEO
to make things happen.
Sometimes that takes me and
her nine months to lock in.
That's easy now on Zoom,
over a glass of wine.
I mean my business development
has changed forever.
I'm going to be far more efficient
using the internet, go figure.
To win that game, because now
everyone's used to Zoom life.
And I think this mixed world of Zoom life
and real life, is very real now.
I think that's going to
be the biggest change,
how I manage my time.
because I'm going to be able
to use virtual as a weapon
to be more efficient.
No more waking up at 4:30 in the morning
for one meeting in Chicago
on a 6:00 a.m. flight
for 12:30 in Chicago
and flying back at six,
that's fucking stupid.
And that's going to be pretty cool,
which will lead to incredible impact.
More time with my kids.
I'm going to catch more basketball games
at 4:30 because I'm in the
city and not in Chicago.
Just more efficiency.
I'm ecstatic.
- There's something too in that,
that we've talked about a lot with
some of our cohort partners.
And the idea of how alumni networks now,
you know there might've been
a, I went to Maryland, right?
So there was a New York City alumni event,
or an LA alumni event.
Now your reach as a college marketer
is instantly across the country.
And it pulls in a lot more people,
which is a good (mumbles)
- Everything wins when
you eliminate friction.
You know why you love Amazon?
'Cause it eliminates friction.
Convenience is king.
This was established a long time ago.
What this culture of
virtual is going to do,
is going to eliminate friction.
There are a lot of things
that you used to not go to
'cause you just couldn't make it.
They just going to go into the Zoom part.
They're going to be many events
that are going be half Zoom half real.
A full 100% networking event right now,
I genuinely believe, we'll
be 137 people in a room
and a screen with what we're
all looking at right now.
And we're doing our thing here.
And then they, you know, it's mixed.
I hate when people, everyone's like,
it's going to be this or
it's going to be this.
There's no extreme.
It's going to be the middle.
It's gonna be mixed.
And I think there's a chance
to make real life events
far more interesting.
And I'm excited about it.
- So let's dive into that a little bit.
So real life events, again,
looking at the sports,
through a sports lens.
How is that hybrid virtual and real life
experience going to change in the future?
- I own coaches club seats
for the New York Jets
and pay a fortune for it.
And I would pay an extra
thousand dollars per game
to be in the locker room
virtually, for a Jets game.
Now, they can get pretty gangster
in those locker rooms after the game.
So I don't know if that's
going to be the thing
that Jets decided to sell.
But if I'm an artist,
if I had the luxury of being Drake, right?
And I'm a businessman,
I'm selling $1,500 a head,
virtual passes, for a cam in
my green room during my tour
for the whole tour.
Now, if I'm doing crazy
shit, or fuck the money,
I need my relaxation, I'm not.
But for Gary V, knowing my personality,
cause I'm not doing dumb shit.
I'm not trying to do bad shit.
And I'm addicted to
fucking human interaction.
I'm fucking doing that
all day long, right?
So it's really gonna be
an interesting thing.
It's completely opened up things.
And what I'm excited about,
is some of the people that
are getting hurt the most,
artists, venues, teams,
I think they're going
to win the most in 2025.
Because if they're going
to innovate on top.
They've just found a ton of revenue
that the limitations of
people physically being there
has opened up.
I think it's going to be unbelievable.
I think it's going to
be the one great once,
I love the concept of one
step back, two steps forward.
I think there's gonna be
a huge two-step forward
for the most innovative
venues, organizations, leagues.
There's a huge opportunity, for access.
We will pay for access,
that virtual will give us
that we can't get otherwise.
- Do you think this is finally the stage
where we've heard about
VR for a long time?
Do you think this is where that access
and that virtual hybrid comes into play
from a VR perspective?
- I do not, as of the short term.
Nobody on this call
knows a real human being
who normally goes on
VR, for an hour a day.
There's no normal human in America
that goes into VR an hour a day.
They're in the business.
They're in B2B.
They're a very edge
technologists that's curious,
but to talk real life, you have
to wait till scale happens.
And until I see humans
spending an hour a day
in entertainment or education
in VR, I can't bet on VR.
- So talking about one step
backwards, two steps forwards,
in the sports industry,
What is the most immediate
step that needs to be taken
to take a big step forward
- To immediately right
now strategize for 2022,
what your virtual monetization
or branding strategy is.
- And have you seen a certain
league or sport or team
already sort of grabbing
that by the horns?
- I have not, but I'm
also not really looking.
So it doesn't mean it's not happening.
But I'll give you a good one.
If you're a Brooklyn Nets fan,
and in their dressing room
right next to it, they
decided to create a greenroom
confessional before the game.
And like two guys per game
are guaranteed to go in there,
and do Q and A like this, for
eight minutes prior to a game.
And you get a season pass of that,
for an extra uptake at $69 or $150.
A ton of people are going to buy that.
- Yeah
- That's a strategy
that if I owned the Jets right
now, I'd be implementing.
The 9:00 a.m. to 10:00 a.m.
Cause I know the football schedule,
confessional in the locker room.
We guarantee you two, you might get more
where the New York Jets, it's a $99 pass.
It's good branding, we
can film the content.
We can distribute the content social.
And if we can get 10,000
fans we could start,
it could be a little nut.
- Totally.
So I think it's time to
pull up our first panelists
to ask a question.
Eric from the University
of South Carolina AD,
I'm going to ask you to unmute
now and ask your question.
- I appreciate it Gary.
Hope you guys can hear me okay.
You've talked about empathy
as a superpower before,
but I've struggled to see how
you can deliver empathy at scale.
When we have 15,000 accounts, families
that we're trying to
develop relationships with.
How would you go about
delivering empathy at scale
- By hiring a ton more people,
and spending a lot less money
on the media distribution
of the content we make?
- Fair enough.
- Yeah I mean, when I buy
the New York Jets Eric,
I swear to God, I plan on
having a one-on-one relationship
with every season ticket holder.
Not me, but I'll be in the
mix cause I'm a character,
but the organization.
And how am I going to do that?
Instead of having a 17 person sales team,
I'm going to have, I'll
probably have that,
but instead of spending money
on billboards and commercials,
to get people to buy season tickets
in August on network television,
I'm going to take those dollars
and I'm going to put it
into, lifetime value,
what I call farmers.
And I'm gonna say, let's
say you were on my team.
And say, Eric, here is your ED3
three season ticket holders.
No like they're your
friends, and (gibberish)
I do this all the time.
I'm building, in the greatest
theater of scalability, right?
In a world where I'm an early investor
in Facebook, Twitter, Instagram.
I've spent the last 10
years building a company
that has 1000 employees.
I believe in scaling the
unscalable through human beings.
So I think you can do it.
But it's a great question.
And of course, technology
with AI and ML and
and you know, app structures,
you could do a lot of scaling
to make you effective and efficient.
But the human spirit,
is something you can't automate or fake.
And so I need to put you in a position
to be able to handle AD3 efficiently
with all the tools I put you around you,
and hopefully continue to advance that.
So you can go to 96,
because maybe with AI,
every time somebody
emails you or text you,
with this exact question,
which is just information,
it can automatically
reply next Friday at four.
You know like that will come along.
And so as AI and machine
learning advances,
all of a sudden the Eric can
handle 813 instead of 83.
And then you got something really brewing.
- I appreciate that, thank you.
- [Gary] Thank you, sir.
- Next we're going to go
to Gab from The Flyers.
Gab, I'm going to ask
you to unmute now too,
and ask your question.
- Hi Gary.
My question is, managing a team remotely,
What are some tips and tricks
to keep the staff engaged,
feeling valued, motivated
in this time when
the unforeseen future of
live events coming back?
- It's really wild.
It's a great segue from Eric's question.
It's almost like the
same deep thesis, right?
Like for example, yesterday,
I just surprised jumped into
like five different meetings,
and just Santa Claused people.
They think they're
having a regular meeting.
I come in, I'm like,
hey, and I'm sending you all
a bottle of champagne, see ya.
That's like a good thing for
a CEO to do, or a leader.
Just being there for people.
Like, how big is your team?
- 10.
- That's a trim for me, right?
Like to me, that's just you
over the next three weeks
individually to those 10
writing a very long email
or a Slack or text long.
Like hey Karen was thinking back
to when you first started that first day
when I spilled all the
coffee on you or did right?
And then it really ends with how are you?
And do you need anything from me?
- [Gab] Thank you.
- The answer is giving a shit.
- Awesome, next we're going to go to
Cooper from the PGA.
- Gary V, good to be
talking to you my man.
- [Gary] Real pleasure Coop.
- My question is, what is the first thing
that you do every day,
and how do you parlay that into success?
And it doesn't necessarily
have to be a task,
but how do you kind of
build on what the, you know
how you start your day and make
that into a successful day?
- It's really funny.
Cause I actually have a real answer,
not like a cliche bullshit answer.
But it's a very weird answer.
I'm basically an operating system.
What I would call like
the way I intake oxygen,
My answer is going to be this way.
I'm not joking.
This is not like I'm fluffy
or Eric's said I'm empathy.
And already said, I'm a good guy.
This is real talk now.
I am so fucking pumped when
I wake up in the morning
and nobody called me in
the middle of the night
to say something atrocious happened,
that I'm like almost shook by gratitude,
that all the dog shit of my business day
almost feels secondary.
Like honestly I literally
go into immediate gratitude.
And then I grab my phone
and look at my texts,
and most of it's like,
this problem in Singapore
this problem in London,
this thing, you know,
this Jet's player's not playing this week.
All bad news, you know?
Because I had that quick,
I don't think it's as like,
it's not as like direct
as meditation Coop, right?
It's not as direct as that.
But I would say 365 days, I
would say 16 to 39 days a year,
it's like directly thoughtful.
Like I'm like, huh, all right.
But it's my constant operating system.
It's how I live my life.
- Gotcha.
And just, you know,
coping with the bad stuff.
Do you, do you just kind of put
yourself into a mental state
where you can handle that
and continue to operate
while, thinking about the good things
and using your successes
to kind of trump all that?
- When I'm most struck right
now, I have a crazy situation
where there's a $10 million delta
between a four year client at VaynerMedia
where I was anticipating something,
and they're coming in at that
level and it's devastating,
it's bad for us.
We're a small company.
200 million is great, but
like and we did it fast,
but it's, it's meaningful.
Literally, this happened today.
Literally I go into, what
if they gave me 40 million,
but I got a text that my
mom's in the emergency room.
I always always put life's perspective
as an overlay over business issues.
- Gotcha, love it.
Thanks for the answer.
- [Gary] Gotcha brother.
- So we also have a question from Carl.
Who's at the Red Sox who
does not want to be on camera
cause he's on baby duty today,
but I'm going to ask it for him.
What is your recommendation
for finding a way
to get whether it's your brand's messaging
or your brand's voice to
stand out in the clutter,
especially when everyone
is now trying to vie
for the same eyeballs?
- By being better.
And I know this is a really
important question my friends.
Since, especially since a
lot of sports talk going on.
A lot of you are private messaging me.
So I'm giving you guys my information.
And here,
actually let's use, let's
use Colin who just hit me up.
If you want to be in New
York Islanders player
you need to be a better hockey player
than the rest of the world.
I love when people are like Gary V,
everything you talk about.
Now, it's hard.
Everyone's doing it.
I'm like uh-huh.
And?
You know, let me say this to everybody
when it comes to marketing.
Your ability to make pictures,
videos, animated gifs,
audio, written word, and then
understanding the context,
of LinkedIn, Facebook, Pinterest,
YouTube, Instagram, Spotify
to make that content work
in the context of the platform,
from a utility standpoint but also
having the intuition and understanding
of the consumers psychology
while they're on it, right?
Betty Tran is not the same human
when she's in her Pinterest feed,
than when she's in her LinkedIn feed.
She's the slightly different version
of herself, mindset-wise.
The picture and video you
put in there, is imperative.
The lack of massively good LinkedIn
strategy, creative and media amplification
that's being done in this room.
When it is the answer to
almost everyone's questions
in this room, is staggering to me.
The reason Eric, I'm going to
be able to afford 85 people
doing that imaginary job,
is cause I'm not going
to need 17 salespeople,
I'm gonna need four.
Because I'm so good at
marketing as a lead gen,
that I'm going to be able to be
more efficient with my dollars.
So that's the answer, I know it's noisy.
Everything is.
Life, it's called,
I love when people are
in competition arenas,
like in the sports business,
and like like perplexed by competition.
Yes, everybody wants to get
that local 50 store chain
in Washington to be the
sponsor, I get that.
And so you must be better than everybody.
Because it's not just you,
it's not just Chanelle versus The Capitals
or the Nationals or the
Orioles or the Ravens.
It's also, that money
could go to Facebook.
That money can go to LinkedIn.
That money can go to Direct Mail.
That money can go to the Baltimore Sun.
And by the way, that's what I
fucking love about this game.
I love competing.
- So, we've,
we were looking at a lot of the questions
that were coming in.
And a lot of people were talking about
when you're creating your own brand,
or wanting to enhance
your own brand voice,
should you concentrate on scale,
or should you concentrate on
exclusivity of that brand?
What do you have to say to that?
- Both work.
Coca-Cola's is a good business.
Country clubs that charge $500,000 a year
are good businesses.
But I think the answer to that
question is self-awareness.
Is your product worth the exclusivity?
And then do you know how
to operate that business?
Otherwise scale is gonna
what you want aspire to.
- And how to play off
that idea of FOMO as well
is something we talk about a lot.
It's a good driver for,
Ari and I've said before,
but latent demand.
There's an interesting angle too-
- Especially when you don't
lose trust with the community
and the consumer.
Because a lot of you create
bullshit exclusivity and demand.
And then when you're stuck
and you still got too much inventory
and you have to get rid of it,
you undermined that execution,
thus becoming vulnerable.
Crying Wolf in this industry,
is the biggest vulnerability.
- Do you have an example of how
that has led a brand astray?
- Everybody who says limited or this that,
and then have to discount,
when it wasn't limited loses.
The end.
- The question-
- It's about then
the strategy of creating
limitation that has demand,
so that you're not forced
into faking the funk.
Because once you lose that
trust with the end consumer,
that they're just going to wait you out
or buy it somewhere
else or secondary this.
You're fucking vulnerable.
- Yeah, for sure.
There's a question that
several actual college students
submitted talking about-
- Hold on, I apologize.
Carl M, for you to put the Trash Talk logo
in your back screen, that's marketing.
You hacked my attention.
I'm impressed, brother.
Let me know if you need a job.
All right keep going.
A question from a couple
of college students,
obviously it's a weird time
to enter the job market.
It's a weird time to be feeling ambitious
and have a lot of doubt
and uncertainty around
the start to your career.
What do you have to say as far as advice
for some of the people entering
the job market right now?
- You don't get to choose what
era you come out of college.
You know, there's people on
here that are like these kids,
I came out in 2008 and nine
during the great recession,
there were no jobs.
That's number one, number two,
you're either winning or losing
in your perspective on life.
The amount of people that are looking
to hire people to do TikTok.
TikTok Creative in 2021 is remarkable.
And who do you think they
think knows how to do that?
All the young people in the
world, even though they may not.
So I would argue that this isn't one
of the greatest eras ever
to go from college into the workforce,
because we have an explosion
of companies hiring content
creators for digital and social,
and they assume the best ones
are the kids out of school.
I think that people are
going to find a humongous,
humongous market.
If they are thoughtful about
what they want to get into,
and are not rigid and saying,
well I have to get a job in this.
If you have some humility and patience,
and you take the jobs that
are there in front of you,
I think there's a huge opportunity.
- Another question on the
sort of job market careers
sort of angle is, a lot
of people are asking
what's been your most effective
way to find motivation
in time of either feeling stagnant
or maybe feeling uninspired or stuck?
- Practicality,
being practical about the situation,
and suffocating entitlement.
I think everybody here needs
to realize that for all of us,
we had the great fortune of being alive
and living in America during
the prime of its empireship.
And if you look at the history of man
over the last hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of years,
the reason those kinds of
situations tend to lose their way
because people get entitled.
People are like crying about things,
that people would literally love to have
just a hundred years ago.
I mean, there's been
harder times than COVID.
We are soft, because we're an empire.
And I think when you understand
that and take a step back,
you can get a lot more grateful,
and realize this will evolve.
And the perspective one deploys
against time like this really matters.
Instead of being upset
for what you don't have,
let's be happy for what you have.
A lot of people died during this pandemic.
If you or someone you love didn't,
that's already a huge win.
Next, a lot of you have
rekindled your relationships
with your children or your plus ones.
Others have learned that their plus ones
might not be for them in the longterm.
And the fact that you weren't
around each other all the time
is why you were sustainable.
And as much as that may
hurt, and may sounds silly.
It's a real gift to realize that,
and hopefully both of those individuals
can go and become happy.
There's a lot of great things
that have happened here.
I also want to remind everybody,
that had COVID started two months earlier,
Kobe Bryant would probably
be alive for 50 more years.
There was a lot of people destined to die
in a traffic accident, over the last year
that lives were saved because
they were stuck in their home.
To me, this is glass half
full versus glass half empty.
And that's how I approach
these kinds of conversations.
- It's a really, really
good way to look at it.
And it's interesting to
think about it like that.
There's also a changing gears slightly,
but I wanted to talk a little bit about,
we hit on it slightly earlier,
but your idea of Santa Clausing
in a couple of meetings,
I love it, I think it's an awesome idea.
We got a lot of questions about,
what separates good leaders
who get the job done,
from a great one?
- Intent.
You know, like what are you about?
You know, I'm trying to get every person
that I have ever spent
any kind of time with
to come to my funeral.
That is my number one KPI.
That was my number one KPI in my life.
My number two KPI, is enjoying the process
of trying to buy the New
York Jets professionally.
That's a framework that allows
me to be a great leader.
You know, like it,
I don't care about
anything other than legacy,
which allows me to make human decisions
instead of financial decisions,
every time I'm passed with them.
I also had the great
luxury of being raised
by a parent, my mom, and
my parents were together.
My dad just worked all the time.
Who instilled disproportionate
self-esteem in me,
but also suffocated entitlement.
So I have confidence
but I don't think I deserve anything.
And if I disappear tomorrow,
I don't think I meant anything
regardless of the accolades.
I mean it.
I'll have hours of good
RIP Gary V comments,
and social and a story
here or two and what?
Like, you know, like I think
when you have humility,
but you layer it with
ambition and kindness
you can create a real great formula.
And I think how real what
just came out of my mouth is,
is the Delta between good and great.
And I think I can end up being great
because I really am not joking to you.
And I think a lot of people
say what I just said,
and don't actually act on it.
I don't think people are
trickable on the record.
I know people might find that stunning.
I don't think it's a sustainable game.
And so I live by that.
- When you talk about sort of humility,
and being human in
career in the workforce,
there's a lot of people that get,
either disillusioned or
worried or apprehensive about
needing to hit numbers and
coming off as disingenuine
or needing to create something out of
what a persona that might
not be themselves, right?
So a lot of the questions that
we saw were, as sales reps,
let's look at that
specifically as the lens,
how do you continue to
be authentic and genuine
but also needed to drive
revenue for your company?
- By quitting if you don't
believe in what you're selling.
You can't imagine how much I love selling,
because I sell shit I believe in.
Whether that was some weird
Pinot Noir from Oregon
when I was in the wine business,
whether that was the
KSWISS sneakers I created,
whether that's wine text,
whether that's VaynerMedia.
I think it's really hard
for people in this room,
if you don't believe in your product
and the thing that you're offering,
you're in a shitty spot, right?
Cause now, because you
inherently are not authentic,
the game is over before you started.
If you think you're selling somebody
an obstructed view seat
because you got to move the inventory,
or if you are trying to sell a suite
and you know they're grossly overpriced
because it's year 13 in your venue,
and the fixtures aren't as
nice as they used to be,
the liquor's a little diluted down,
no more Grey goose, that's now Smirnoff,
You know what I mean?
You got to believe in
what you fucking sell.
And, and by the way,
I'm not interested in
sitting in my high horse.
If you actually sitting here and saying,
I actually don't, but fuck Gary.
like, I can't quit my job.
You don't have to do it right now,
but you need to recognize it's true.
And you should start the
process of figuring that out.
Otherwise you're going to
be a cliche salesperson,
and they're going to feel it.
- Yeah I think we're going to
bring up the next person now.
And Chanelle from The
Washington Football Team.
I wanted to ask you to
unmute and ask your question.
- All right, yeah so Gary,
you have a very strong message
as it relates to authenticity.
So, you know, what
advice would you give us
on how to build authentic
client relationships
without coming off as phony?
- You know, I like to
tell people the truth.
Rachel if you came to me and
I was DC Wine Business, right?
And you're like, look, I'm
trying to get your business.
I'm like, I respect that.
I'm like, let's talk about it.
You know, like, hey, I'm about The Skins
and I want to be on the field,
and you're going to trick me with that.
Then that's going to be the real hook
why buy that $80,000 sponsorship.
But like, can you make it worth
for my business a little bit better?
You know, like just real, it works.
And by the way, you're
talking to somebody at 13
who was more full of shit
than anybody I've ever met.
I had a lot of gift of gab.
I was a raw street kid
that came from nothing
and I was just trying to win.
So I know what it looks like.
And honesty and candor, and ambition,
and kindness and listening,
listening is a beast.
You know, I'm so confusing to
people because I talk so much,
I have a certain way of talking.
I'm sure there's people here
that have cursed a little bit
that don't like, I respect that.
I come from where I come
from, I am who I am.
But every minute I'm not
doing this, I'm listening.
And in that listening, it's
really made me powerful.
And I think listening, right?
If you see a big business in
your region going on TikTok
and going am, you're listening.
Got it?
So when you call and be like Carl,
you're killing it on TikTok.
Do you want to be our first sponsor
on our pregame TikTok campaign?
You see where I'm going?
You're innovating, you're
watching, you're listening,
you're watching, you're listening.
Don't come with the same
playbook to everybody.
Contextualize that shit.
- Next, we are going to-
- By the way Carl said radical candor.
And Carl, I look at it as kind candor.
I've got a little bit of a
slightly different tweak,
because candor can be tough.
Because people are insecure
and they get nervous.
I've been thrown around
something called kind candor,
which is you're going
to shoot it straight,
come with compassion and
empathy, and nice and tender.
So really important
part of being a leader.
If you got to tell, you know,
if Alicia Lynch has to tell somebody
that they're not performing,
if you can come with
kindness around that candor,
you have a much better shot
because when you just go with candor,
most people will take it
and drive with insecurity
and get fear-based.
And it throws off the whole system.
You can't do matter of fact
candor, because 90% of people
are gonna start looking
for a job an hour later.
Cause they think you're
gonna fire them in a month.
Even though you thought
about it as a good thing,
you got to come with kind candor.
Hey, Carl, you just been here six months.
You know what I mean?
I get it.
You know, maybe you're
struggling with COVID.
I'm here for you.
How do I make it better?
Because I'm seeing this shortcoming.
By the way, on the record,
the greatest vulnerability
of my entire 25 year career, candor.
I'm incredibly candorous
on stage, like right now,
and for my community, but as a manager,
because my father, was
a mean candor deliverer,
I demonized candor as a child.
I didn't realize it, probably
the last two three years,
recognition for me.
And so I'm on my journey,
and I see the I see the benefits,
and it was a real vulnerability.
Candor is a vulnerability,
because then you're bullshit.
And bullshit's bad.
But I just also recognize most
people struggled with candor.
So this kind candor really matters.
- Ben Conrad from The Bucks,
I'm going to ask you to unmute.
- Hey Gary.
- Hey Ben.
- Hey my question,
my question is, I know
you're a super bullish
on search through AI and voice.
For brands like that are
live event, you know, sports.
Where do you see,
and how do you see us
having to prepare for that?
Knowing that right now
it's not top of mind
but it will be soon,
and then I also was curious what the,
if you had to pick a under $30 red today,
what would you buy?
- I would buy Portuguese Reds.
Portuguese Reds are by
far the most under priced
quality red wines in the world,
the Douro, D-O-U-R-O,
or the Doa D-O-A, are
two incredible regions.
But they're so bad at marketing,
that nobody really knows them.
Portugal's known for port,
but the red wines, the 25 bucks,
could rival $70 wines
from France in the US.
So that's that answer,
got a little nerdy on you.
I believe in a decade, from this moment,
I will be sitting in my house and say,
hey Alexa what's the best deal on tickets
for the Knicks game tonight?
And everybody here needs
to prepare for that.
Hey, Alexa what's the best concert lineup
coming up this month?
Hey Alexa, you know, when COVID is over,
can you remind me to go
to two baseball games
and find me a good deal?
This is all gonna happen.
I think it's a decade, so that's sometime.
But humans will always
pick lack of friction.
And people are confused, because
right now everyone's like,
hey, Alexa you know,
play Billy Joel, right?
It's early.
But to remind everybody
the number one iPhone app,
in the first year of the iPhone,
was the drinking the beer app.
Where it looked like, because it was early
and we weren't innovating yet.
Alexa, and Google home, and Apple,
and whoever else gets into it,
are going to be major,
major, major players.
It's going to happen,
it's lack of friction.
It's faster.
It's faster for me to say,
Alexa, send me a pizza.
Than it is for me to open
my Seamless app right now
and buy a pizza.
Not to mention that
Alexa is going to know,
or Google Home especially,
that's as a huge thing.
Cause it will know a
lot of my information.
I mean, Google, set up a meeting with Ari
as soon as possible.
And Ari is also on Google Home,
and Google infrastructure,
Google calendars,
and it literally looks
at our two calendars
and sets up a meeting for us.
In our both open spots.
AI and voice is gonna be game-changing,
the way that our grandparents
looked at an iPhone,
a lot of you are going to
look at AI voice that way,
it's going to change your life.
And you're going to have
to be prepared for that.
You know, when for the OGs in here,
when Google came along
and customers got smarter
and knew information
that fucked your game up.
Imagine now getting the
perfect answer from AI.
Not I'm going to spend 40 minutes,
to find the best seat deal,
the mathematical equation
to the best seat deal.
That's a very different
game in one second.
Because I wouldn't spend
the time looking for it.
I value my time too much,
but if I'm going to Milwaukee on business,
and the bucks are a really
fun team to watch right now,
and I'm like hey, Alexa, get
me the best deal on courtside
for the bucks game when I go
there, on my calendar, right?
It's gonna be efficient.
- Awesome, thank you.
- Which goes back to my bigger point.
Which is the challenge
is going to be for us,
is to make quality products,
not be good at selling mediocre products.
- Something else that
we wanted to bring up
to a lot of people were asking about.
As far as not so much the tech
in the future, but the trends.
A lot of people asked
about sports memorabilia,
sports cards, I know you've been
talking a lot about it recently.
What is your sort of overall thought on
the trend of that industry,
and where has it gone in the last year
compared to where am I going
in the next two or three?
- I mean, sports cards are very hot,
because I think they're contemporary art
for the 35 to 45 year old
contemporary modern high
net worth individual.
Like I'm not buying a
fucking Jackson Pollock,
but I wanna Bill Russell
perfect rim, you know?
And so you're going to see that play out.
There's also a gambling element now.
You can buy a pack of cards
and pull a $500,000 Zion.
That's crazy, full-pledged gambling.
So I think that market
has a really good run.
You have real serious
people coming into it now.
I think you're gonna see a big,
long weave of prosperity in that market
and it will ebb and flow.
Certain people are gonna
lose a ton of money on it.
Cause they're going to bet
the farm on Kendrick Nunn or,
or Tyler Hero or Zion or John Moran.
And unfortunately some of those players
won't become the best players ever,
and that will have liabilities
to the way people invested in them.
But as an overall market,
I think it's got a lot of potential.
And I think, you know, I
think for a lot of people
that are trying to create experiences
at that macro level, I
think cards are incredible.
And we know this.
Everybody here knows this,
like giveaways at the
stadium are really smart.
Bobble heads were a
huge driver for awhile.
I think people had a very
smart sports card strategy,
and were able to navigate around
the Panini and Tops rules,
meaning properly and figuring
out what they can do.
I think they could be
incredible arbitrage mechanisms.
Back to what I said
earlier, being smart, right?
If all the upper bowl tickets
came with a limited edition pack of cards
that was exclusive to
your stadium that season,
you would sell out because
people are going to ARB
the E-bay sell-through against
literally come to the games
just for the content of the card.
So I think there's a
lot of smart innovation
that I would think about in that arena.
- What do you think about,
cause it also plays
into two things, right?
The marketability of athletes,
and how each league is handling that.
And also the rise of, you know.
the Robin, it's been the Robin hood year.
Everybody wants to invest.
Everybody wants alternative investments.
We just got a question from Sam.
Who's asking, interesting
on how these sports card
and sports memorabilia is
sort of a good indicator
of the marketability of leagues athletes
and how they're doing.
So you look at the difference
between the NBA and the MLB.
There's a, you know,
the Trout card did well.
- You could, yes.
But the Trout card, if
you look at the long tail
outside of Trout, I mean,
there are you couldn't pick two leagues
that are further apart right now
in understanding consumers
than MLB and NBA.
- Yeah.
It's an interesting way to look
at the trends of both, isn't it?
The sports-
- Oh, and it's very clear like,
this is a modern American
society is an NBA,
proper football soccer,
UFC, Esports culture,
where the NFL has to be very thoughtful,
where Major League Baseball
is in a really shitty spot,
if you're playing out 15, 20 years.
I mean the MLB decided to
make a lot of money with bam
in the short-term digitally.
And create a dictatorship
that doesn't allow children
to see content.
Mike Trout can walk down
Madison Avenue route naked
and nobody will know who
the fuck who the he is.
You know, that's insane to me.
And especially baseball.
America is exploding in
our Latino influence,
and we are sitting with Juan
Soto, Vladimir Guerrero Jr.
Fernando Tatis, Javier Baez,
I mean this is insanity.
And they're doing nothing about it.
It's atrocious, it's the
biggest reason my brother and I
have gone into the baseball business.
We expanded Banner Sports
into baseball because
these kids have to make
more money off the field,
it's crazy.
- Goes back to scale versus exclusivity.
- Yes, thank you, Matt.
I didn't even pick the
best player of them all
Cooney junior, I mean,
it's fucking insane.
Glendora, I mean, you know, yes.
- It's very interesting.
So-
- Literally the fact that
the third star on The Bucks
is more famous than Aaron
Judge, is ridiculous, and true.
Baseball's lost lost her way.
And has nothing to do with, you know,
and you know what the
disguise a baseball is,
is it's a summertime sport,
it's a nice night out, right?
You go to the ballpark.
The problem is soccer is
gonna take that business.
I'll bet the house, 25 years from now,
that's summertime sport activity,
soccer's gotta huge land
grab against that guy and gal
and kid that go to watch something.
And by the way, don't
let the NBA or the NFL
decide to change the
time of year they play.
One of the, back to the,
remember the early question.
That was a different,
the first question you had about
how COVID changed consumer behavior.
- Yes.
- Yes good, okay.
Here's one, the NBA season
shifted because of COVID.
- Or having an NFL game on a Wednesday.
- Well, there's that, but
that's not sustainable.
What is sustainable is three or four
of the most influential
NBA owners saying, huh,
and this may or may I
have no clue, but like
they might be like, huh, this is better.
They might, and then that's a
big ass problem for baseball.
- It was even a good example of looking
at Paul Rabil and the
PLL Tour League Model.
- Because wrestling in the Icecapades
in the circus is a good business
and people had forgotten about it.
And Paul did a great job,
and you're going to see many more do it.
- I think we already saw the
NWSL, tried it this year too.
It was-
- Right, and then Conner's bring it.
We're not even talking about Anna May,
and like celebrity box things
in a different place in our culture.
What you think, you think
people that want to make money,
are gonna just look the other way
to the Nate Robinson, Jake Paul situation?
You can see every fucking person
you don't want in the internet fight.
I'm probably gonna have
to fight next year.
So,
- We just got a very interesting question
on this too, from Michael.
There's a digital token aspect in Esports.
Fortnight's huge on it.
Is there that equip, has
any league or team or split-
- By the way, real quick, I apologize.
JB asked me who I want to fight.
I just want to give the
official answer, Tom Brady.
Just on the record,
if we ever can get that fight made.
So just want to give that answer.
So go ahead.
You were saying digital tokens.
- Yeah.
- Block blockchain,
virtual currency.
The whole world is based on IP.
The plate, do you understand
how close the MBA is
to going out of business?
I'm so excited to drop this on everybody.
Do you know how close the NBA
is to going out of business?
Let me play it out for you.
Cause this is a brain thought compared
to the last seven minutes of us talking.
- Yeah.
- The NBA is so star oriented,
that if LeBron and Greek
Freak, Steph, Durant
and let's just pick 15 of the next
Luka, Donovan Mitchell, Zion,
got together in a secret cave 30 deep,
texted 30 billionaires that
are not owners of the NBA.
Bezos, Shmezos, Sarah Blakely.
Well, I guess Blakely's husband
is involved with the Hawks,
but nonetheless, do you understand
that if the 30 best NBA players
went to dinner right now,
texted 30 billionaires
that are not in the league,
and said would you want
to be my 50/50 JV partner?
I own 50% of team.
You put up all the money,
and you own 50% of the team,
that I believe the NBA would fold?
Interesting debate, fun pot fodder.
But the reason I bring that up is,
the fact that nobody here,
said that's completely outlandish.
Like that's stupid.
Because you would have said
that if I said it 35 years ago.
The fact that nobody said it's stupid,
that you may not agree.
And honestly, I'm not saying it will.
I'm just saying it's fascinating
to me because I believe it.
Everyone's like, oh,
the NBA's so brilliant.
They're doing such a good job
in marketing their players.
They're so brilliant.
I'm like,
you think the NCAA made these new rules
of kids being able to make money,
or go to the league in 2023
because they wanted to?
Get the outta here.
The internet collapses the middle.
The internet is distribution,
nothing else is distribution.
And I think we're going through innovation
that will bring twist people.
And I think what I just said
about the NBA is scary close.
- What do you think is
the first to crack that?
- The NBA.
They're the most top heavy.
- [Drew] Yeah.
- And their homies.
This isn't the era of Bird and Magic,
and Jordan and Ewing.
These guys, I mean Carmelo, Chris Paul,
Dwayne Wade and LeBron might be
drinking wine together
right now, as we sit.
These guys, they don't
appease me as the fan.
I need them to hate each other.
I hate the way they fucking do
this, but I love it for them.
I hate it for me the fan.
When I lose a Jets game, I want
to punch people in the face.
But like for them as humans, I love it.
And I love the leverage.
And I think it's scarier
than people think.
And closer than people think.
- So I, you, you hit on this
a little bit before but,
if you had to pick a sport,
and I'm including Esports
in this, obviously.
What would you pick to take over the
vast majority of the market
share over the next 10 years?
Is it soccer?
Is it Esports?
- Are you asking which sport net net
I'm betting on the most?
- Correct.
- From a financial standpoint,
like a business standpoint.
- Yes.
- Esports.
It's, imperpetuity scalable.
And it's clearly already won, right?
So it's not limited to physical location.
What's better Amazon or Walmart?
Amazon.
Now, if Walmart does a great job
at walmart.com, they'd right?
But like the internet wins.
And so Esports and the (mumbles)
is fascinated by Esports
and is watching Twitch
and is in consideration,
and it's on the radar.
VaynerSports represents a
kid by the name of Bugha.
Who won the Fortnite Championship.
He's one of the best Esports
players in the world,
he's more famous to
the average 14 year old
than a stunning percentage of
professional athletes today.
- Do you think-
- By the way
by the way.
somebody said, hey Gary didn't Kyrie
try to do that before the bubble?
Yeah, that's an early
indication to how close this is.
Michael Jordan, it didn't
cross Michael Jordan's mind.
But Kyrie's flirting.
So think about that.
Play out the chess moves another 20 years.
- Yeah.
Do you think there's a world where
one of the other major sports
makes a play to create
a hybrid of an Esport?
Like you've seen MLS teams
bring on EMLS players.
You've seen the same thing with the NBA.
You've seen it around, but
is there a way that that
really can be married, or
is it one or the other?
- No, I think, look,
I think anybody has permission
to do anything, right?
Like I think if MLB or
singularly, the Minnesota Twins
or I think when I think
life's about execution, right?
Good call out by Latham on NASCAR.
They've done some nice executions,
and they have a different model.
I think, I think wrestling, you know WWE
can own its infrastructure
in a different way.
Given the dictatorship that that work
(Gary mumbling)
You know, there's some things out there.
It's just execution.
If you're an owner of a sports, you know,
I'm wearing a VersionOne Esports team
I'm the minority owner of the
Minnesota VersionOne team,
Rocker in Call of Duty VersionOne in,
in Rocket League VersionOne
is going to be the holding
cone, the brand to be built.
You know, that's The Wilfs
the owners of, The Vikings,
they're my partners, and if we
do a good job executing here,
nothing stopped them
from being good at it.
Meanwhile, I don't know if Bob Kraft's
thrilled with his investment in his world
because it hasn't gone as well.
You know, just depends,
it's all execution.
- So I know we're, we're almost
running out on time here.
So I want to sort of try to wrap it up
with a question on what
we've talked about,
the trends for the future.
We've talked about more
career workplace things.
If there's one thing you could leave
the vast majority of the sports
and live entertainment business
that people on this call are here today,
with advice for the future,
what would you tell them?
- Anything short of
disproportionate obsession
with bringing the other person
value is a vulnerability.
The consumer has the leverage.
The options are infinite and
there's no place for audacity,
or entitlement, or history or
how you think it should be,
this is the game of listening
and understanding what
to bring people in value.
And I think that's the game.
- Awesome, well I want to thank you Gary,
for an awesome hour.
I want to thank Ari for
getting this all together,
and I thank everyone for joining.
We're going to be sending out a recap,
a recording of this video.
Over the next week or so,
and I wanna have everybody
have a happy holiday season
and thank you Gary again so much.
- Thank you, RF, go team.
Thanks all of you.
I appreciate all the comments I'm seeing.
I really just, I wish
everybody super well.
I shared some of my
information throughout here.
Have a great, great, great holiday season
and new years, cheers.
YouTube watchers what's up, it's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also want to ask you,
please subscribe because my commitment
and exploration of YouTube
is about to explode.
Stories, polls, more
content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.